at least one generally predictable genre
has been shaken up over the last few
days the genre presidential debates and
interviews the man who shook it up
Tucker Carlson Tucker hosted a candidate
Forum in Des Moines Iowa The Blaze aired
it and it wasn't a proper presidential
debate in that he was just grilling
candidates individually
the Tucker woke up Friday morning and
Tucker chose violence and Tucker burned
down about half the GOP Presidential
field the most brutal exchange of the
day was with Mike Pence and it concerned
the war in Ukraine
you are you are distressed that the
ukrainians don't have enough American
tanks every city in the United States
has become much worse over the past
three years drive around there's not one
city that's gotten better in the United
States and it's visible our economy has
degraded the suicide rate has jumped
public filth and disorder and crime have
exponentially increased and yet your
concern is that the ukrainians a country
most people can't find on a map who've
received tens of billions of U.S tax
dollars don't have enough tanks I think
it's a fair question to ask like where's
the concern for the United States in
that well it's not my concern
foreign
Tucker I've heard that routine from you
before but that's not my concern
I'm running for president of the United
States because I think this country's in
a lot of trouble
I think Joe Biden has weakened America
at home and abroad
and as president of the United States
we're going to restore Law and Order in
our cities we're going to secure our
border we're going to get this economy
moving again
okay
it's a terrible answer it was a terrible
answer it almost certainly destroyed
what chance there was for Mike Pence's
presidential campaign and yet
I think
Pence's critics are being a little
disingenuous here it seems clear enough
to me that Mike Pence was not actually
saying that the American interest is not
his concern I know that's what it sounds
like but if we're being charitable and
we're being honest here I don't think
that's actually what he's saying Tucker
says
well all this terrible stuff's happening
in America your concern is that Ukraine
doesn't have enough American tanks well
where's the concern for the American
interest and Mike Pence says that's not
my concern
what do you think he's referring to
there do you think he's referring to
that little bit at the end or do you
think that Mike Pence started
formulating his answer when Tucker said
your concern is that you cry doesn't
have enough American tanks and he was
planning to give this canned package to
answer which he immediately launches
into which is America's in trouble you
know he just he just goes right into the
stem speech it's obviously the latter
and yet
the result is going to be the same
it's it's not that people are dunking on
Pence here because of his his answer in
this Exchange
people are highlighting this exchange
because they already want to dunk on
pens because they already don't support
him I know the effect of that is is
identical but
he's not really saying that it's just
that people believe that his
the the uncharitable way of interpreting
his answer gets to a deeper truth
perhaps an unwitting and unconscious
truth about Pence's answer which is they
view Mike Pence
as being a representative of this
mid-2000s kind of Republican Orthodoxy
that's much more concerned about cutting
taxes at home not really fighting the
culture War all that hard and policing
the world and engaging in Adventures
abroad fair or unfair that's what they
think that Pence is after and Pence's
answer did not do him any service there
Pence though by the way always had a
pretty much impossible path in this
presidential race
the people who support Trump
hate him because Pence refused to hold
up the certification of the votes on
Election Day
the people who hate Trump hate Pence
because Pence made a deal with the devil
and served as the vice president for
Trump for four years so his support base
basically did not exist and he's been
trying to navigate these two Fields it
was it was not going to work and then
Tucker came in and just pulled that pin
out of the grenade threw it into the
Mike Pence presidential campaign and
fairly or unfairly completely blew it up
right now go to goodranchors.com use
promo code at Knowles you know I love
anything made with top of the line
quality for me that is good ranchers
period the only thing missing
is a pork box
and then if you ask they deliver good
ranchers has just launched their Prime
poor 100 American pork that is
Steakhouse quality this new pork box
comes with bone-in and boneless pork
chops sausage smoked brats and more plus
right now you will get 30 bucks off with
code Knowles kwles goodranchers.com on
their site
you can explore all their All-American
cuts of prime pork Prime Beef and better
than organic chicken options if you've
tried their beef and chicken before you
know how phenomenal it is you got to try
this Prime pork at least once trust me
these guys the quality is unsurpassed
and the other guys don't even come close
it's it's my favorite meal it's my
favorite meal that I can look forward to
of any regular week when I come home
what are you waiting for enjoy real meat
and real service today with good
Ranchers go to goodranchers.com use code
Knowles Canada wlas for 30 bucks off any
box promo code Knowles Canada Wes
goodranches.com goodranches.com American
meat delivered the other candidate who
did not fare terribly well
from this grilling by Tucker
Senator Tim Scott
stop this war and reach a piece as as
one does where both sides you know
concede some of their interests like why
wouldn't that be in our interest to do
that I think the faster we get the piece
the better off we are what we don't want
to do from my perspective is allow
ourselves to ask for a premature piece
that cannot be achieved as the alliances
continue to come together to the extent
that we can find our path out of this
situation the better off we are so
what's the point at which we'll know
that we've achieved our goal just and I
say that within the context of having
watched 20 years of occupation in
Afghanistan where nobody could answer
the question what's the point and no one
in Congress ever asked that question
amazingly so what is the what is the
specific goal here yeah so I would say
that the objective should be for
salinsky and Ukraine to be able to
achieve Victory by maintaining as much
of their territory as they possibly can
and then seeing the resources that we've
deployed along with our Western
alliances
achieving the peace that I believe comes
when you get these two folks to sit down
and have a conversation that allows them
to determine where those lines will be
drawn for the next hundred years okay
Tucker just lets it go okay but Tim
Scott didn't say anything there
he did his best and he's a nice guy but
he didn't say anything he said I want
peace but we need we we shouldn't
achieve a piece before we can have a
peace that is achievable
and Tucker presses him and says well
what's that look like
when do we know we've achieved the peace
that is achievable he says well it's
when these guys Putin and and so let's
see when they sit down and they have a
conversation
okay what's the point of the
conversation well the point of
conversation is going to be they're
going to work out what the limits are
yeah right that's the question what are
the limits what what is it what is the
okay check check check we've got our
we've accomplished our goals now the war
is over well he says it a little bit
earlier in the answer he says well it's
when zelinski can keep as much of his
land as he possibly can okay well as
much of his land as he possibly can keep
is all of it
so now you're saying that the war is
going to continue until Ukraine
maintains its territorial integrity
that it had before what two years ago
that it had before 2014 that it had
before the invasion of Crimea that it
had
that's never going to happen this is a
Thousand-Year territorial dispute that
we're talking about in Ukraine so Tim
Scott's answer effectively is we're
going to have War forever which was the
which was the answer in Afghanistan but
the the imperialists who supported that
didn't have the courage of their
convictions to actually say it
maintaining an overseas Empire is a
common theme throughout history and it's
a defensible position might not be your
position might not be my position it's a
defensible one but the people who were
arguing for that
couldn't really make the argument they
didn't want to make the argument because
when when you ask these imperialists
when you ask these foreign adventurists
what is the goal of this war
the answer is the goal is to keep it
going
and what the more conservative people
are saying right now lowercase C
conservative they're saying well you
know
when you're just engaged in an
open-ended war with a nuclear former
superpower where you're encroaching on a
buffer state that previously separated
you two guys who were at a on the brink
of nuclear war for the back half of the
20th century closest we've ever come to
an all-out nuclear war
uh that gets pretty
dangerous
and no one except for like one guy at a
Canada Forum no one seems to want to
press the candidates on that question as
we all Sleepwalk into World War Three
boy what a great clip that was make sure
you ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael Knowles show
we'll see you next time